[Music]
when i look back at each of my books
there are chapters or elements or
messages that i wish i'd maybe
emphasized more
or that i'm
sad get
skipped over or not given enough
attention
in the new book are there any
chapters or concepts
anything at all that you really hope
people do not
miss i know that's perhaps a strange way
to phrase it but
i'll leave it there as a starting point
it's almost like
i felt i could just print the title the
title page the myth of normal
trauma illness and healing in a toxic
culture and just have people write their
own books you know
just have a bunch of empty pages
so i think the message is reinforced
through the whole book
what we think is normal in our society
from the point of view of human needs
and human evolution is absolutely
abnormal
and therefore what we think of
abnormalities in terms of illnesses and
and and dysfunctions and diseases and so
on
these are normal responses to abnormal
circumstances
and the biggest loss you and i already
talked about this is a society that from
the very beginning from in utero onwards
put stresses on human beings
that they lose contact with themselves
and the essence of trauma is loss of
contact with yourself loss of connection
to yourself
and that's reinforced through parenting
practices
the parenting advice people get you and
i already talked about that
it's reinforced in your school system
but it's all about competition and
evaluation
rather than
relaxation and learning
we're judged all the time by by our
externals like how we look
what we achieve
how smart we are how fast we are we're
not accepted for who we are with our
flaws and our vulnerabilities
society caters to those false needs
so that
you know
for god's sakes people are botoxing
themselves
because they've learned that how they
are is just not acceptable
people are
on facebook presenting a false image of
themselves because
they believe that how they are and who
they are is not good enough
we sold all these products and um
are
manipulated into all these activities
that are
all attempts to fulfill some deep hunger
in ourselves
that is missing because we've lost our
two cells
we are
manipulated
into buying products and eating foods
that are actually toxically addictively
unhealthy
and this happens with the full awareness
event not on the awareness the
the employment of modern science
as to how to get people hooked on cell
phones or junk foods
our politics reflects
very traumatized people reaching the top
enacting policies that then create more
trauma for large numbers of people
in other words this is a society that
for all its wealth scientific ingenuity
incredible progress in science and and
medicine
has fundamentally got disconnected from
the essence of what it means to be human
beings
and we suffer there's an article in the
new yorker about
the alarming rise in childhood suicide
the mysterious rise in child there's
nothing mysterious about it kids are
stressed
because of the conditions of this
culture all the lonely people as the
beatles sang you know
all the lonely people
the number of people lonely has doubled
in the last 30 years
britain has appointed a minister of
loneliness
loneliness kills
it's as dangerous as smoking 15
cigarettes a day
in terms of causing illness or or
potentiating illness and death
there's so many ways in which this
culture is
abnormal
and it's causing people to be not well
and so
that message
that's the essential one that i hope
people won't miss but i i kind of doubt
that they will if they read the book
and the big message is tim is we don't
have to be that way
it's not our true nature
we even sold a bill of goods about what
human nature is
human acres not like that and precisely
the reason there's so much dysfunction
is because we've got disconnect from our
true nature we don't have to be we can
find our way back
we can embrace it
and we'll be a lot healthier both as a
group and as individuals
you